hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines in this episode I'll work on
everything when it comes to the center
of the city and probably not finish it
entirely are definitely a couple of
loose ends then I want to tie it
together at some point in the future and
there's probably a lot to improve as
well so I would like to at some point
probably incorporate some feedback into
it but the basic shape of the city will
definitely be made as well as putting in
all the buildings or nearly all of them
really and also adding some details on
the streets and actually experimenting a
bit with adding the textures over the
roads instead of just using the road
textures themselves because I really
wanted to have some brick textures just
to make it look a bit more like it's an
actual Dutch city that's said though I
probably need to talk about the newest
update of the game since I haven't
actually tried to open the game since
the newest update yet I actually haven't
played the game since I just haven't
really found the time to given my recent
addiction to planet coaster so I won't
actually be messing with I think that
pronounced Keys or any of the new
additions to the game I've definitely
seen them and I might want to
incorporate them at some point in the
future in this city so far everything is
just with the snowfall things which I
think this is actually the first
snowfall episode though are not 100%
sure about that but definitely you can
still tell that at this point in time
there is still a very awkward reflection
on the road whenever it would rained and
also something to keep in mind about the
fact that this was in snowfall is that
ever since my traffic plus-plus didn't
work and even though I got the game to
work again I haven't been able to get
the city file to work as well as getting
the pedestrian paths of traffic plus
plus so that means that what was
formerly all of the concrete roads is
now gravel roads because I don't have
the traffic plus plus concrete
pedestrian roads anymore and that is
sort of an issue in a sense that many of
the gravel roads around the city are
actually supposed to be concrete roads
and I need to get back to those and
actually change them slightly so that's
also why that's part of the reason why I
wanted or
ended up having gravel roads around this
center of the city anyway a bit more
about the center of the city itself it's
very much inspired by William starts
mostly there are many different star
forts in the Netherlands but I wanted to
look at bilam start specifically since
it really has a very distinctly star
shape many of the star forts do have the
overall star shapes battlements on the
side of the city but bilham's thought
this one that actually has a real star
shape and isn't d-formed in any way so
that was a major inspiration especially
when it comes to the road layouts since
much like film start this one is laid
out on a type of grid with more or less
a sort of central road going through
through the city day where I want to
have some central parks and also some
central churches and some of the more
fancy buildings of this city in general
and then around that I wanted to quickly
have those quick Islands the idea was to
have these islands as you normally see
them around starforce as well but in the
end it sort of came out a bit sketchy
which is definitely due to the fact that
there's a rock tech here on that I would
have preferred to be able to have cross
textures on that so this definitely
works much better from an aerial
perspective than from looking at it from
the ground I think but yeah that's the
general idea and also something which is
sort of unique though when it comes to
the city if you compare to Willem start
and makes it more similar to other star
forts is the fact that there is
obviously canal going through it which
pretty much came with the map which I
decided to keep in there and so it still
has something which really
differentiates it from Willem stop as
well now in terms of the buildings they
are pretty much a very random Rhapsody
of different Dutch looking their own
buildings which I found on the Steam
Workshop but I do have to say I'm not
entirely happy about it in hindsight
there are a couple of realism issues in
the sense that realistically some of the
buildings are a bit strangely scaled I
think this is something I will get back
to at some point in the future in real
time I'm not entirely sure so this is
something I should address anyway
because it's quite a glaring
you at the moment is the very fact that
many of the row houses which I use as
you can see the very amsterdam ish
looking canal houses are really
beautiful but they are very large
especially compared to the other houses
which I'm using among which the Dutch
row houses but also the envelop slot
houses which were actually on the Steam
Workshop as well and this is an issue
that I just sort of still had in this
episode like you can very clearly tell
over here that some of the houses are
much smaller than different ones so that
is something which I do still want to
change a little bit in the future and at
least chip away in edit in such a way
that the awkward scaling isn't as
obvious anymore in the end but that's
pretty much the only real issue I have
house wise otherwise I'm actually really
surprised at how many Dutch buildings
there still are and how well actually
came out in the end though something I
should also add is that this was
recorded quite a while back I think one
week or so after snowfall was actually
released so talking a really long time
ago and at the time I didn't have the
new Dutch houses yet which are currently
on the workshop which I definitely would
love to pick up for the city but
something to keep in mind is that I am
kind of behind when it comes to the
footage in that regard so I didn't have
them at this point in time yet
and something else which is sort of a
glaring issue at this point in time as
well is that the surrounding of the city
isn't going to be finished yet so I just
wanted to very quickly sketch out the
surrounding shape of the dikes that will
be around the centre of the city here
but not entirely finish it and I will
still leave that unfinished work quite a
while until I have a really good idea
about what I want to do with it which I
don't really have at the moment and I
rather just focus on the details within
the city itself which speaking of which
it was actually a lot of fun to work
with the foliage over here I wanted to
do something which is very similar to
what many Star Wars have as well just
some very grid like three lines around
the outer road and also some different
three lines around the inner roads as
well and some foliage in between both
areas
which I think really just helps to mark
out the shape of the city a little bit
more and think in the end I was quite
happy with how that looked so I
basically just wanted to get all of
these oak trees around the side of the
island just following the road like that
and then have a second layer of they're
called summer trees I'm not entirely
sure what type of tree it would
realistically be but wanted to have that
layer within that as well and then next
to the city at least have some more
foliage which is placed a little bit
less manually and a bit more like
natural foliage and that's really what I
wanted to do with this you do see many
Starboard's which have grass on the
sides of the hills but I really just
thought it would look a little bit
better to have trees over here and also
in a way sort of helps get rid of the
issue that everything looks so very
Rocky which I wish it didn't and I might
still want to look into themes with
which I can at least get grouse
everywhere even on cliff faces which i
think would be really amazing because
the rocks start appearing even at pretty
gentle slopes but that's something which
I have still to look into and also
something which I got many requests for
is to build a city wall around this
island instead of just keeping the
little dike like this and while it's
something which I definitely thought
about and tried to get some different
walls into the game to see if I could
actually make it happen
there are a couple of issues with it and
some reasons why I decided not to go
with a war in the end first of all I
don't think there are any walls which
very convincingly look like Dutch
constables many of them are either very
Mediterranean or medieval ish and I
haven't checked in a few weeks now but
at least at a time when I was building
this I didn't think there were any
convincingly Dutch looking walls that I
could use and also many of the star
forts if not most these days don't have
their walls anymore but rather just have
these dikes where the walls once stood
in pretty much the same shape which is
what I wanted to do over here and which
is what in the end I think looks just a
bit more realistic than trying to get a
wall in there just for the hell of it I
suppose
though of course still if anybody has
any
type of suggestion or feedback to give
about the series a way to improve I'm
always up for that and I lightly see
what I can do with it that sounded way
too professional I I just like taking
feedback and it's always great to also
be able to look at things from another
perspective and definitely some things
especially when it comes to knowing
about certain things in the workshop
that I haven't noticed myself especially
since I don't check every day anymore
and more like twice a week I might
definitely miss some things as well and
our definitely also some things in the
end which I'm not so sure about anyway I
wanted to also detail the city over here
and at the small Plaza here just to
decorate this a bit since I really
figured this main strip in the middle of
the island could serve as sort of the
park and more official building strip
which is why I wanted to have that small
Museum over there and also a church in
the middle of it which is quite similar
to how Valen start does it as well and
aside from that also make some quick
parks in there and beside that I really
have to fill the town up with a lot of
foliage because there is also one other
issue which I sort of have with these
buildings which is that Dutch buildings
in especially towns like this even
though they tend to be very narrow and
not that high they go on for very long
they're very long so you even though
these blocks are pretty wide in real
life you would see pretty much is very
long narrow strips of houses with just
very small alleys in streets in between
them which is something which I couldn't
really do here because the houses are
only two titles deep there is one which
is four tiles deep which is a little
better but it still doesn't get the job
done very realistically so looking back
at how the city looks one of my main
issues with it is also that it even
though it has the overall shape and the
building's really looked like touch
buildings in general it doesn't quite
have the building layouts that you would
realistically see from Dutch cities
because the houses and buildings in
general are much smaller which is partly
sort of alleviated by having those
really large blocks but then again those
blocks aren't very typically Dutch and I
think are actually meant for Dutch towns
actually
so they're not the most representative
of Holland basically is what I'm trying
to say so there are definitely some
things which I would still like to
improve on the city centre but still I
do have to say as well I'm actually
quite happy with how it turned out so
far I got many requests to actually
finally make this episode while I was
working on the other episodes but I
really wanted to wait this out until I
got enough assets and knew for sure that
I could make at least something decent
out of it which is why it took so long
but which is also why at least I'm not
too unhappy about it there's just still
of room for improvement I think and I
also just wanted to very quickly finish
this part over here
with something quick though I do have to
say about that I made a terrible mistake
that I actually played some football
post over here thinking well this would
be perfect for a football field and then
at some points not recording I just I
think I wasn't recording at the time I
just looked back at the field and turns
out that the field was on a slope and
having a football field on a slope isn't
entirely the best thing ever so decided
to at least get rid of that and over
here I wanted to have the parking places
since I really wanted the centre of the
city to be as car-free as possible so
sort of realistically tourists would be
able to car park their car in here and
then move over a bridge to actually go
to the city centre so you'd be able to
keep the cars and all the heavy traffic
out of the city centre which in city
skylines though doesn't really work
everybody just visits this car park for
visiting the car park because it's a
park but that's really just the idea for
it realistically and since the other
place where I put the entrance to the
city was also sort of just put up there
in a hurry just to have a quick entrance
to the city but there was no room really
for parking places on the other side and
there won't be any room for it since I
will also have some small housing
developments near that area and then
over here I just wanted to quickly
finish this Park in a sort of simple way
but this is where I wanted to have new
houses as well which is
one of the decisions which looking back
at it I'm still not so sure about it I
try to make it into a part first but
then I was really thinking I have like
if this is a park I would have an
amazingly huge park area sort of around
the city center and a lot of space which
I wouldn't do anything with and I was
really figuring it would be kind of
awkward to have that around the Central
Station there but this is also something
which I'm definitely up for feedback to
as well because I'm still not sure if I
really want to keep the houses over here
the idea was basically to just at least
make this area a bit more dense and make
the housing developments over here fit
in with the houses which I already have
on the other side of this road and give
that sort of modern suburban style to it
which even though I'm quite happy with
how this small development came out and
it's really inspired by the really small
developments which are very newly
planned around cities I'm not quite sure
if the placement around here is really
the best and yet I also feel like if I'm
in place this housing development here
I'm not sure what else I would really
place here so I'm really on the fence
about this area regardless of that
though this is what it look like at the
moment and this is what it looked like
at the moment which is just some simple
houses very large gardens and very large
houses as well and just wanted to make
this really one of those more modern and
spaced out housing developments but
still I'm very unsure about the
placement and not to mention that it's
of course it's awkward it's awkward ly
close to the city centre as well but
also it sort of is just underneath that
main road over there and very close to
the canal as well so it even though it
looks sort of spaced out it really has
an awkward placement in the city and the
general issue I guess really boils down
to if I keep this place empty it feels
like too large of an empty field to keep
in the park or keeping the city and if I
make it a park it would really feel like
there are too many parks in this area
yet to keep it as a little neighborhood
with houses it would feel like it's a
little bit too forced and too small
- oddly placed over here so I'm really
not entirely sure what I really want to
do with that here so that's I guess why
I would be up for feedback I am in the
end still quite happy with how it looks
it's do something which I'm not sure if
I really want to place it in the city
like this and now I just wanted to very
quickly add some more foliage to at
least make that a little bit nicer
around the city but the main thing which
I'll actually be doing in the remainder
of this episode is get the road textures
done which is something which I really
wanted to try which I haven't tried up
to this point is to just replace all the
roads with gravel roads to make sure
that they're all flat and actually put
my own textures over them or at least
particulars over them manually which is
something which I really wanted to try
because having the asphalt roads is just
something which is quite rare in the
Netherlands anyway when it comes to the
three types of roads in the Netherlands
and you have the roads that are used
within neighborhoods and for people to
get to run their houses they are barely
if at all asphalt roads and really one
of my main issues with the city as a
whole is also that it uses so many
asphalt roads because there is barely
any other way except for while doing
this manually for every single part of
the city but also just because
especially when it comes to city centres
the colour and tacky of the roads really
makes a really huge difference to how
the city overall looks and so I really
wanted to try and get some more fancy
bricks textures in here not you not just
to make it look a little bit more
traditional and old-fashioned but also
to get it to look a little bit better as
well and it also allows for a couple of
those fun things which often Dutch roads
do and the other parts of town of in the
older parts of towns where where
different roads meet up there'd be
planters or a different brick texture or
some type of brick pattern on the middle
of the road and things like that which
is I think also fun thing to mess around
with and also of course have some
sidewalks on the side which is actually
a lot of fun as well so it's really I
like doing it in terms of that I think
it makes a huge difference in how the
town overall looks which I'm quite happy
with but in the end it is a very
time-consuming thing so I don't think
I'll
be doing it for the rest of the city at
all it's really just for the city center
because it makes a largest difference
for the city center then it really does
for the rest of the neighbourhoods which
at least looks somewhat alright with
with all of the s port roads though that
said I did that I do think it was Bo for
me I'm not entirely sure at least some
mother is actually at the moment working
on brick road and I think it's Network
extensions here which would be so
awesome to have but until that time this
is pretty much all that I can do and all
that I pretty much wanted to do and
aside from that I did also want to
detail it a bit especially since gravel
roads on their own don't have any
lanterns and I wanted to keep it that
way just to be able to place the
lanterns myself and get the exact
placement which I would want in
different places like for instance it's
really nice to have if you have these
very large facades be able to actually
plan your lanterns around them and also
plan some planters and benches around
them as well not to mention some small
tables and stuff like that to make
everything look a bit more alive and
like there are actually restaurants and
really that kind of stuff is when I was
trying to go for here and aside from
that I definitely also wanted to have
some trees on the roads though not as
much as I would have realistically had
and this is also one of the big
limitations of really what you can do I
guess in the game because I already had
so many different trees in the city just
to fill up the holes between the
different roads since the houses are not
as long as real touch houses are I
didn't want to fill the roads up with
too many trees either or this entire
city center would just end up looking
like a forest and I do have to say while
in the end I'm quite happy with how it
turned out
it's really not that's entirely
realistically Dutch and I may still want
to get back to it but then again I'm not
sure how much better it'll really get in
the future since it's really hard to get
this to be exactly right but yeah I
might want to return to it anyway thank
you guys for watching this episode next
time I should be doing something which
is going to be a little bit easier to
actually tackle which will be various
detailing around the city and the
university as well so thank you guys for
watching and see you later